well through the covet pandemic many of
us have faced our own personal
challenges
overcoming them can be challenging and
it really requires resiliency
and brian someone well qualified to talk
about resiliency is jim davidson
the mountain climber summited mount
everest in 2017
two years after he was nearly killed in
an earthquake on the mountain
well his story is one of survival
followed by success
in some pretty tough circumstances
here's his first-hand account from that
2015 earthquake all of a sudden
the glacier jerked into the air and
lifted the tent up and then we dropped
back down
and then we went back up again as the
waves rippled through the glacier and
being in the tent was like being in a
life raft out on the ocean and that's
when i knew it was an earthquake
and when that happened we could hear the
roar of avalanches we're having an
earthquake all at once
it was pure survival mode for a good
couple of minutes
after surviving that earthquake jim and
his team were rescued from mount everest
they then spent the remainder of their
adventure helping those in nepal who'd
lost
everything clean up and begin the
rebuilding process
but two years later jim returned to
mount everest to try again this time
he made it jim says while you may not be
a mountain climber
we all have our own personal everest and
many of the tools he used to overcome
his challenges
can be used by all of us to help
overcome ours
whether it's an earthquake recovery or a
pandemic or an economic crisis
you help them they help you somebody
else helps and we're all slowly lifting
each other up and we'll have bad days
when someone stumbles and that's when
someone needs to lift them up again
as you move forward through life you
might have a big aspiration but things
are going to go sideways
there's going to be earthquakes there's
going to be pandemics so how can you be
resilient enough to endure the bad
things when they're happening
try and grow from it and re-engage with
the next set of challenges
the next opportunity the next everest
so jim has a recounted both of his
everest experiences and detailed how we
can all use resiliency to survive
challenges
he's got a new book it is titled there
it is the next everest
you can read it now and watch an
extended interview with jim just head to
our website at 8newsnow.com and
click on the everest story for all of
those inspiring details guys